どおおおおおーーーーもおおおおーーーー
どーもーー！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと
こんにちは、 くｍ
よく、 コメントで 来るんですよ。
女装しろ、みたいな
じょしょうしろ(笑笑)
女 装 し ろ 、 み た い な の が 来 る ん で す け れ ども
僕は、 一、男として 女装 と 言 う も の に は こ う ち ょ っ と 、 抵 抗 が あ る ん で す よ
けどやっぱり♪
皆さんが、しろしろと言うからぁ
今日は　くまみき　さんにですね、女装を、
あっ、違、くまみきさんがするんじゃなくて
く ま み き さ ん に 、 僕 を 女 装  し・・・ても ら う
どう？なんて言えばいいの
私が、はじめしゃちょーを、女装、さ、せ、ま、す
イェーーーー
く ま み き さ ん は で す ね 、 原 宿 系 の フ ァ ッ シ ョ ン の 、
ファッションモンスターなんですよね？
原宿系 ファッション モンスター なんで、
原宿系の、 その、 グッズとか ファッションを、 こう、 中心に 活動しておられる。
なので、 僕は今日原宿系の、 女装になります。
結構行けるんじゃないかなと思うんで・・・
ほんとですか
ちょっと、ゴリゴリの、原宿系にしたいと思います(笑)
お 化 粧 す る 前 に 、着 替 え な い と いけ な い ん で 、 ま ず、 ち ょ っ と 着 替 え か ら し て 行 き ま し ょ う
じゃ、着替えてきます。　　っせーの!!
せーの！
こんな感じになりました。
これでも見せてもいいんですよね？、中。
そ！見せて良いやつ
ニーハイとかも履いてるんで
(笑)  毛ぇ生えとる
絶対領域
これが 絶対領域
着替えが終わったので、今から
メ イ キ ン グ タ イ ミ ン グ ア タ ッ キ ン グ チ ャ ン ス ｲ ィ ン グ で す か ？
メイキングアタッキング、、、、、、チャンシング＊＊＊＊＊＊＊＊、、、、、、！
よろしくお願いします
おねがいします
完成まで僕は分りません
く ま み き さ ん だ け が 解 っ て る 状 況 な の で 後 は お 任 せ し  ま す
はーい、 じゃ前髪だけ留めてもらって
え？難しくてできない
嘘でしょ(笑)
えー
デキる！
ﾃﾞｷﾅｲ出来ない
はじめならできるよ！
難しいよぉ
じゃ、ファンデーション塗りましょう
はい
やっぱ、基本はファンデーションですよね
先ずはね？
女はファンデーションから始まるんですよね？  やっぱり全ては
全ては、ファンデーションから。１０円ショップのファンデーションから
え？１００円ショップのファンデーションで良いんですか？
えっと、パウダー、ハイライトから
凄い、肌のトーンが上がってきた。
おおおおおぅ
私はそれを正面で食らうんだけど(笑)
ちょっと、鼻、んーって伸ばして？
オーケー
ハイライト、肌の、高い所を高く見せよう
あ、それでこの　おうとつが出来るわけですか
あそそそそ
どうしようかな、♪
やる(笑)
これって、アレですか？睫毛を・・・こうするやつですよね
こうするヤツ
痛くないんですか？これは
痛くないよ？
超勇気あるね？
コワい！
大ジョブうううううーーーはあああーーー
痛い？
大ジョブ、全然痛くない
あの、全然ｱｯﾋﾟﾝｸﾞしましたね。
ｱｯﾋﾟﾝｸﾞしました
そしたらアイシャドウ何色がいい？
美味しそうな、こういう色と、
こんな、オレンジ系と、イエロー
イエローとピンクにしよう
はい
伸ばした方が描きやすいんですよね？
うん、書きやすい
ちょっと、こっち向いて
わ、ｷﾗｷﾗいれてる！
今、ｷﾗｷﾗ入れて・・・
その内ブスッて刺しそうだよね
塗れないんだけど？(笑)
これぐらいですか？
うん、これぐらい。　イエローを下に入れよう
なるほど
上向いて？
目、目だけ
あ、目だけ
それだよ、その顔だよ。
マジっすか？これだってゆうんですか
この顔塗りやすい
女子は涙袋ですよ
うー！　コワ！　ヤバ！　うわー！　目に入るよ～
おかあさん・・・
頭どうしようか？　出来るだけ・・・・
出来るだけやってみます？
有る物全部つけたくなるね
出来たー・出来たー
ありがとございまーす
ど、どうですか？
っか、っわ、いい、みたいな感じ
か、わ、いい、ですか？
僕は自分の顔見てないので、実際に、見てみようと思います。
くまみきさん、お願いします。
いきまーす
はい
せーの！　ｼﾞｬーーーﾝ
あ、あ、見たことある、この人
誰？
何か見たことある！
ｳｯ､　ﾒｯ､　ナンか　ﾈｺ目、　猫目っぽい
ここが凄いですね、いい感じ
いるよね？って感じ
いそうですか？
いる
こんな感じで
原宿系ファッションの女の子になってしまいました。
うわーーーーーーー
くまみきさんのチャンネルが動画の、ぁぁ
くまみきさんの動画のチャンエルが、説明欄にあるのでぜひ。
こっちには僕と一緒に撮ってる動画が有るので良かったら観て下さいね
See you next time ~
ﾈ、ﾈ？　足長いからモデルさんみたい~
問題はすね毛ですね・・・「すね毛ですね」・・・　ふふ